We are hearing from people via discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's go to Liz in Salt Lake City.
I don't know that we get too many callers
from Utah.
Liz, tell me what's going on there.
And you please do set to do not disturb.
I'm already before even hearing you, hearing
your discord, bleeping and blabbing.
So please set that to do not disturb.
And I would love to hear from you.
Hey, David.
Hello.
Hey.
So I'm calling in from Salt Lake, and I was
just curious, what are the chances that Donald
Trump and his family will be prosecuted after
leaving office?
I think it's very low.
I do believe that there is a good chance that
there's going to be all sorts of investigation
and maybe even settlements or fines for Donald
Trump's businesses.
I really don't see criminal charges coming
for the Trump family.
It's not the way this country has operated.
I'm not saying it shouldn't.
I'm just saying I don't expect it to happen.
OK.
And I've got one more question for you.
What are the chances that Don Junior is going
to run for office in the future?
And, you know, what state do you think will
accept him and make that a reality and unfortunate
reality that he might run in the future?
Well, what do you mean?
What state will accept him?
Like, where does he have a chance of running?
Will he get like a second home and become
a resident of, like, Alabama or something?
You're saying he's good, but would he be running
for president or for Senate?
Senate maybe like a governor working his way
to the White House or ambitious especially?
Oh, he does.
Is speech just how he supports his dad?
So I was just curious, like, who will accept
him?
Do you think he has a future in politics?
I don't see it.
But I you know, I think he's pretty self-serving.
And I think at this point we would be naive
to say he has no future.
And in fact, when I talk about the importance
of removing Trump now, if we don't, I think
that 2024 much more naturally leads to a Trump
kid running for something.
And so as much as it is important to vote
Trump out now for the sake of the world, it's
important to vote Trump out now to not allow
one of the kids an easier path in 2024.
I think that if it listen, if the Republican
Party voted for Trump in the Republican primary,
they would potentially vote for Don Junior
as well.
And we've got to make sure we don't we don't
make that any easier for them.
Telo.
OK.
All right.
Liz is gone, I guess.
Very, very good.
Important question.
Very, very
important question.